- [Voiceover] Today we're
gonna talk about the
sign convention for passive components.
It's a big mouthful, but
it's a fairly simple idea.
Well first of all, let's
look at this word passive.
Passive is the way we describe
components that do not create power
or components that do not amplify signals.
So particularly resistors,
as we have one here.
Does not amplify a signal.
Capacitors and inductors do not either.
So all three of those
are passive components.
And sometimes we say
something like a battery
or a voltage source is a passive component
because it can't amplify a signal.
It does provide power, but it
does not make signals bigger,
it can't make a voltage
larger than it already is.
So we're gonna start with the
way to label this resistor
with its current and voltage.
First we'll resort to Ohm's law,
our friend,
voltage equals current,
which is i times r,
and when we label this,
when we label this device,
here's a resistor, so
we'll give that a label,
and we're gonna put a voltage across this,
something outside of this is
gonna put a voltage across it
and this end will be positive
with respect to this end.
And the question is, the
question we want to answer is
which direction does the current go?
When the positive voltage is here
and the negative voltage is here,
which way's the current
flow through this resistor?
Does it go from top to
bottom, or bottom to top?
The answer is the positive
current goes this way,
it goes down, so that's i in this.
And the current is going into
the end with the positive
sign on the voltage.
Now I'm gonna draw another one of these,
same sort of thing, and
we'll do it a different way.
We'll do this one sideways.
And I'll label the voltage, here's r,
and I'll put a voltage on it,
and the voltage let's label it this way,
we label the plus end this way
and label the minus end this way.
The question is which
way does the current go?
Well the current goes in the positive end
so it goes in that way.
And that's the sign convention
for passive components.
The current goes into
the voltage on the positive
terminal or the voltage.
If I drew the arrow over here like this,
that would still mean the same thing,
it's still going in the positive
and coming out the negative side.
So when we draw this for
capacitors and inductors,
let's draw a capacitor over here,
and there's c, and if I
labeled this with a voltage,
plus and minus v,
then the passive sign convention tells me
that I label the positive
current going in, i.
The same for an inductor.
We'll draw a curly inductor,
like that, we'll put a
voltage on it this time.
I'll put the voltage on
this side, plus, minus v,
this is our inductor, like that,
and the current,
the current goes in the top like that.
So it goes in the same side as the plus.
And the current comes
out on the minus side.
You can draw it either way you want.
Let's practice some more,
this time we'll do it
with a resistor, again.
Here's another resistor, and
this time I'm gonna label
the current first.
I'm gonna say the current goes
this way through the resistor.
And now, using the passive component
sign convention, how do
we label the voltage?
I wanna label the voltage.
Where's the plus sign?
Plus sign is on the side
that the current goes in.
The current's going in to this terminal,
so that is the plus side
of the resistor.
And that's basically the
idea of a sign convention
for passive components.
When we're setting up a circuit,
if we have a complicated circuit,
we're setting it up, we have to give names
to all the voltages and all the currents.
And this is the way you
do it to make sure that
Ohm's law comes out with the correct sign.
That's why we have this sign convention.